nous sommes donc toute cette semaine en
direct de la porte de versailles à paris
le salon de l'agriculture a commencé
samedi
on retrouve sur place arthur nice arthur
la filière bio a de plus en plus de
poids au salon notamment pour les
producteurs de notre région
oui exactement ce logo vous voyez
peut-être derrière moi c'est celui de l'
agence bio je suis avec son directeur
florent gül bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous qu'est ce que c'est que l' agence
bio
bonsoir balle agence bio c'est la
plateforme de développement de
l'agriculture biologique en france qui
regroupe à la fois les pouvoirs publics
le ministère de l'agriculture le
ministère de l'écologie mais aussi les
professionnels du secteur les chambres
d'agriculture la fnab le synabio et les
coopératives par qui êtes-vous finances
et du coup instinct financement qui est
complètement public donc par l'état par
des crédits européens qui financent
l'ensemble de nos actions le directeur
c'est le ministère de l'écologie on
dépend du ministère de l'agriculture est
aussi un peu du ministère de l'écologie
on va on a interrogé tout à l'heure un
peu plus tôt dans l'après midi un
exploitant agricole bio qui est dans
l'indre et loire
je vous propose de l'écouter ben moi
j'utilise aucun aucun produit
phytosanitaire donc
même pas du cuivre parce que le cubisme
autorisé en bio mais en céréales j'ai
fait le choix de
de ne pas l'utiliser voilà aujourd'hui
sans mes cultures
je traite pas j'ai pas de pulvérisateurs
mais c'est une autre façon c'est une
autre façon de travailler donc ça permet
on se remet en cause
c'est une nouvelle approche donc il ya
plus de travail du sol
on joue sur les rotations sur
l'interculture voilà et
on conjugue tout ça pour essayer d'avoir
un rendement satisfaisant
voilà sylvain qui a récupéré une
exploitation avicole en 2011 mais nous a
avoué que même si l'exploitation n'avait
pas été biologique ici serait mis de lui
même alors il ya de plus en plus de
personnes qui vont vers l'agriculture
biologique
oui c'est très spectaculaire depuis
plusieurs années encore plus en 2018
si on prend l'exemple bien sûr de la
région centre val de loire on a
aujourd'hui en 2018 plus de 230 nouveaux
agriculteurs bio une progression de plus
de 20% en un an
donc oui c'est une dynamique est
vraiment très très importante et qui
montre le chemin finalement pour
d'autres agriculteurs bio également
demain donc c'est pas en fait un simple
effet de mode
non ce n'est pas un effet de mode on est
du côté à la fois des consommateurs et
des producteurs vers une vraie envie
d'aller vers l'agriculture biologique
c'est une façon de reconnecter justement
les consommateurs et les producteurs
c'est une façon d'aller vers une
agriculture plus respectueuse de
l'environnement et pour les agriculteurs
on l'a vu dans ce reportage c'est aussi
une façon de retrouver un métier qui est
pour eux plus complet finalement on a
rencontré également tout à l'heure
geneviève elle et artisans et
productrice dans le loir-et-cher écoutez
là c'est très compliqué très chronophage
en heure
et en plus en argent l'inscription pour
être reconnu en tant que bio pour
vérifier tous les dossiers c'est ça
minimum
500 euros alors on l'a entendu la
volonté est là mais c'est compliqué ça
coûte cher
est ce que ça coûte au final beaucoup
plus cher que l'agriculture
traditionnelle
oui c'est un des sujets importants mais
sur ça coûte plus cher de produire en
bio ça coûte plus cher pourquoi parce
que on a des rendements plus faibles ont
produit moins à l'hectare parce que il
ya plus de main d'oeuvre
il ya plus de temps de travail sur le
pour produire en bio est effectivement
le coût des contrôles cac aborde cette
personne c'est important aussi puisque
l'agriculture biologique et contrôler au
moins une fois par an aux différentes
étapes donc à la fois chez l'agriculteur
le transformateur le distributeur de
tout ça ça a un coût les français quand
on les interroge de 10 oui on a
conscience qu'un produit bio c'est plus
cher et en même temps c'est aussi une
limite à la consommation qu'on connaît
ils nous disent la même façon ben c'est
un frein j'ai pas forcément le budget
donc j'achète de temps en temps des
produits bio quand je peux quand j'en ai
les moyens mais j'ai pas le budget mais
on voit la publicité partout et cette
contrainte budgétaire il est vraiment
présente elle est très présente il faut
réussir à résoudre cette question là
donc on le voit notamment au sein dans
l'agriculture on voit le développement
d'une commercialisation locale de ce
qu'on appelle les circuits courts
finalement une façon de diminuer le
nombre d'intermédiaires et d'accéder à
des produits bio locaux de qualité de
bien rémunérer les agriculteurs et choix
d'avoir un achat qui n'est pas si cher
que ça merci beaucoup florent gül le
directeur de l'agencé bio logique on se
retrouve demain pour parler de sécurité
alimentaire